let's go next to our caller from the 559
area code who's calling today from five
five nine
hey david uh this is nick from l.a nick
from la what's going on i hear it's hot
there very hot
oh yeah it's been pretty hard um around
the 118
121 i think it was in woodland hills wow
yeah um a fan of your show i actually uh
know you from uh um it was like a long
time ago like probably about eight years
ago when you had an interview with um
with um anonymous okay and then what's
the
bro baptist church yes um i have two
i have two quick questions you know my
um
one i wanted to know if um
i wanted to know if if it was possible
for
let's say donald trump to go um
left on some policies do you think he
would actually do that in order to
try to win re-election i don't know that
there's anything trump can i mean we've
got seven weeks
and more and more people are going to be
voting early in absentee so a lot of
people
in four weeks a lot of people will have
voted i don't know that there's time now
for donald trump to get any policy done
i mean he can he can throw some
executive orders together if he thinks
it will help him
but uh i think it's too late for policy
for trump
i would say thank you for that um one
last question um
let's say if joe biden wins or uh wins
the election
and um let's say that um
he tried to impose like a mass policy
but then do you think like any of the
trump supporters or any
conservatives might actually like follow
by it i just don't see that happening
i'm sorry you said if joe biden tries to
implement what kind of policy
like like a math policy like uh like a
mandatory math policy
for for every state are you saying meth
like crystal methamphetamine i'm trying
to i'm not just not sure i'm
understanding no no no
math math mask policy oh my god i
thought you said a math policy
listen here's the deal here's the deal
uh with that
so um ultimately it's up to governors
it's unclear whether legally the the
president can
make everybody have to wear a mask
because a lot of those decisions are
just state level decisions
but if it if it's logical to say
everybody should wear a mask for the
next two months because of what's going
on
i think joe biden will suggest it and i
think
most governors will do it um and you
know what the political fallout is i
don't know i think on that issue i think
if it's the right thing to do biden will
do it
awesome thank you so much if i don't if
you don't mind i'd like to give like a
quick shuttle
uh before i go i really appreciate it
okay um
like to like the shout out to uh
kalinski okay i do
and uh the writing on the hill there was
two uh year three are the ones i usually
listen to every
every day so i do appreciate it very
much all right thank you very
much appreciate the phone call